hey this is presh talwalkar
in a previous video i explained a trick
to solve the following problem
imagine you have x to the power of x to
the power of x to the power of x
and so on repeated infinitely many times
and you want all of that to be equal to
two
how can you solve this problem
now by solve i meant how would you find
an answer in a high school math
competition as fast as possible
i was asked this problem in a high
school math competition and the first
person to get the answer got the points
nearly everyone loved this one minute
video which never claimed to be a
rigorous proof presented in a graduate
level real analysis course
so what was the trick
you could look at this equation and
there's a pattern
consider all of the exponents above the
base
you have x to the power of x to the
power of x and so on repeated infinitely
many times
now all of that is equal to 2.
therefore we can substitute 2
for the exponent of this base of x
so we then have x to the power of 2 is
equal to 2.
now we're looking for a positive root so
we get x is equal to the square root of
2.
and that is correct that square root of
2 to the power of square root of 2 to
the power square root of 2 repeated
infinitely many times is equal to 2.
now some of the people who watch this
video actually had some interesting
follow-up emails to me including andrew
george p
divide dolev oliver and vinit
they tried applying the method i
presented
to another problem
so imagine you have this infinite tower
of exponents
set equal to four
well using the same trick as before
we would then have 4 being equal to x
raised to all these infinite powers
so we end up with x to the power of 4 is
equal to 4.
now if we take the fourth root of four
and we're looking for a positive root we
end up with x is equal to square root of
two
so we seemingly have that square root of
two raised to the power of square root
of two raised to the power squared two
infinitely many times is also equal to
four
and this raises a potential paradox
so we've shown that four is equal to two
but this is clearly absurd
so where is the mistake in the supposed
proof
can you figure it out
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for an explanation
[Music]
so here's a short explanation
this equation or x raised to the power
of x infinitely many times is equal to 4
this is the mistake this equation
actually has no solution
so any subsequent steps are not true
it's like starting out with the equation
x plus four is equal to x plus two
you could subtract x from both sides and
you would seemingly prove that four is
equal to two but we have not really
proved anything our original equation
has no solution
and similarly this original equation
where we set this infinite tower of
exponentials equal to 4 this has no
solution so anything that we deduce from
that will not be true
so for a little bit of a longer
explanation imagine we have this
infinite tower of exponents
x to the power of x all the way
infinitely many times equal to y
this is known as tetration or it's also
sometimes referred to as power tower
super exponentiation iterated
exponentials or hyperpower
so in order to solve for x we must first
check that a solution exists
in other words you want to check for
values of x that converge to a value
for proof i refer you to the
award-winning paper by arthur kenoble
exponentials reiterated in the american
mathematical monthly in 1981
i provided a link in the video
description
so we can plot out this function
it actually has the following curve
the minimum value is x is equal to 1
divided by e to the power of e
and that has a value of y equals 1 over
e
now when x is equal to 1 y is also equal
to 1
and then the maximum value for which
this converges
is x is equal to e to the power
1 divided by e
and this gives the maximum value of y
which is e
so the range of this function goes
between
1 over e and e
and the domain is between 1 over e to
the power of e
and e to the power of 1 over e
so if you have values outside of these
ranges
you're not going to get a solution
so to bring it back
for y equals 2 this is within the range
of this function so we can find a
solution x is equal to square root of 2.
but for y equals 4 there is no solution
as this value exceeds the maximum value
of the infinite power tower
so this problem reminds us of a very
important point
whenever you have an infinite number of
items you generally need to check for
convergence before you simply start
making substitutions and doing usual
arithmetic to solve for an answer
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com